welcome to the 2020 billboard music
awards y'all
what there's no audience this is me yeah
kelly clarkson pulled double duty
hosting and opening the show on
wednesday
alongside pentatonix and sheila e to
kick off a night of
epic performances
[Music]
[Applause]
among the hours of non-stop
entertainment k-pop sensation bts's
explosive performance was
dynamite
[Music]
earlier in the show john legend took the
stage and
emotions were high this is for chrissy
just weeks after chrissy teigen
announced she and her husband lost their
third child legend delivered a poignant
performance of
never break for his wife
[Music]
and demi lovato didn't let headlines
about her recent breakup stop her from
commanding the stage with her powerful
new song
commander-in-chief commander-in-chief
honestly if i did the
sleep things honorary recipients
included
garth brooks who cher presented with
this year's icon award
garth brooks has had at least one top 10
hit single on a billboard chart
in five straight decades garth delivered
a medley of hits spanning his legendary
30-plus year career it's the honor
i mean the award is very very sweet and
you know never be taken for granted
killer mike was awarded with the
inaugural billboard change maker award
for his work in social justice
activism and promoting change the kids
that are organizing plot and playing and
strategizing
right there on the ground and mobilizing
you are needed more than ever tonight's
big winners were
on hand to collect their awards of billy
eilish taking home three
post malone winning nine awards that
kelly brought out on a
cart that's pretty badass i'm gonna take
a couple it'll be fine
and lizzo used her winning moment to
remind her fans to keep going
when people try to suppress something
it's normally because that thing holds
power
they're afraid of your power there's
power in who you are
there's power in your voice i love y'all
god bless y'all
bye [ __ ]
you